david i understand voting by mail but
why should states accept ballots after
election day
after all election day is election day
fair question let's assume you're asking
it in good faith
the uh the population that wants to vote
should be allowed to vote up until
election day
and if you want to vote absentee
you should be allowed to do it so the
only possible correct solution
is as long as your ballot has been sent
by election day it should count and in
particular
when you think so before i go further
if the ballot has to be received by
election day as is the rule in some
states and i disagree with it
you really only have until if you assume
it could take four days for the ballot
to be delivered
you really only have until october 30th
the 31st to vote but
election day is november 3rd why should
you be denied
by four days when you can send in your
ballot
if you are still able to do it before
election day
by election day you should be allowed to
do it now on top of that
when you recognize the way in which the
postal service
has been attacked by donald trump's
postmaster general he now says
that he's not doing any more stuff do we
trust it do we not listen there's just
questions
we don't want votes to be able to be
disqualified
just because the postal service delays
the mail
if the ballot is postmarked by november
3rd
that is what should matter now if you
want to be really cynical
the post office could as they gather the
ballots on november 2nd and november 3rd
wait until november 4th and postmark
them then and get them disqualified that
way
we're now talking about a more sort of
uh invasive
level of of suppression but there is
really no good reason for which
you should not have your vote counted as
long as you send it
by election day we have a pandemic
expecting more vote by mail than ever
we're already seeing it we've already
seen
by some reports more than 60 million
votes already cast could be
close to half of the total or electorate
it's unbelievable numbers
we want to make sure these votes are
counted and if you vote by november 3rd
it should be counted
one last thought not only are we going
to see more vote by mail than ever
before
we are going to see a lot of new voters
voting for the first time by mail
some mistakes are going to be made and i
believe
that we should as if we have the goal
not of being ticky tacky and figuring
out ways to disqualify ballots which is
what republicans want to do
what i want to do is we should do
everything we can
to get as many people as possible
legally voting
we want time for people who make
mistakes
on their ballots to be notified
and to be able to resubmit or decide to
go in in person
and i know that that'll sound weird to a
lot of people who want to be very very
litigious and
regimented and strict father morality
sort of approach
if we believe that democracy is best
served by high voter participation and i
do believe that
then we should be doing everything we
can to get as many people to
successfully vote
period and if you believe that you of
course
should be allowing every vote to be
counted that is postmarked by election
day